let's talk about this tweet from jack
posobik
this guy jackpot antifa book.com he's
got he's got some nerve
he said this should be this should be
illegal in all 50 states and
punishable by federal prison time was he
referring to
it's a twitter thread where cultural
husbandry uh notes
blackrock is buying every single family
house they can find paying 20 to 50
above asking price and outbidding normal
home buyers
why are corporations pension funds and
property investments group groups buying
entire neighborhoods
well he goes on to say it's basically
the great reset the middle class
uses home ownership land ownership to
transfer wealth to their children
but what happens when during a great
reset or i'm sorry during a pandemic
there's a great reset as it were of
people's jobs of businesses
everybody gets knocked out of the
playing field sort of levels a lot of
people out their businesses are closed
family businesses these are some of the
most horrifying stories companies that
have been around for like 100 years
gone overnight now these people are
going to become
renters many moved they want to buy
houses it's not that hard to buy a house
people think it is
but all of a sudden you find us out
you're on zillow.com and you're flicking
and you're like man this is so cool look
at this house
and then you call the agent and he says
oof just sold
for 50k above asking you're like how am
i supposed to compete with that as a
regular person
how are millennials supposed to build
wealth when these companies are coming
in
and buying up all's property yeah i mean
they're not i wish that that uh jack
follow we're here so we could have a
conversation with him on his
perspective on the matter but i think
that what is happening is is terrible
i'm generally a fan of the free market
but part of why this was possible was
because the government came down
and they shut down the the government
came in they shut down the entire
economy for months
and then they also printed a bunch of
money inflating the dollar
and so for your average person given the
savings they had prior it's going to be
much more difficult for them to afford a
house and these massive companies
are going to be able to so it's a
consolidation of wealth the likes of
which i predicted would occur
as a result of this bailout and as a
result of the shutdown and it has
and the fact is people who don't own
property are much easier to control
and check this out you can't even build
a house now so this was reported back in
april
it's about 40 grand more to build a
house today because of the skyrocketing
lumber and steel prices which have only
gone higher
so imagine this it's it's july of last
year
you got a few thousand dollars in
savings and you're like i got enough to
put down on buying a house
not anymore you don't maybe you were
like okay i saved up enough
to actually get a loan for a new
construction not anymore you don't that
new contract is way too expensive so
what happens
not only that not only has it become
harder because of inflation and
skyrocketing materials prices
you finally are like well i have enough
i've saved enough i've overcome these
these challenges and then sorry
blackrock outbid you by
twenty-five percent yeah and you know
going off which
so jack is here and turns out that guy
is here
um yeah this you're absolutely right
though this
was a situation where the government
said you see fannie mae deciding to want
to do this to say
look all of these people went underwater
in their
you know they we call it remember the
toxic subprime loans and the mortgages
and people were buying houses they
couldn't afford et cetera et cetera
okay we know how that started we know
who the people who are responsible for
it
but we live in this strange system where
the same people who are called upon to
fix it are actually the ones who created
the problem in the first place and then
how it goes so who do they turn to
oh you know themselves who could solve
this problem
we can we'll buy it ourselves and
then and the one that he actually
doesn't mention in the thread but i
would throw out there
that's it's and it's just absolutely
huge and you see so many
wealthy chinese families coming in
chinese elites ccp elites that know
that their money is if it's in a chinese
banks and you've run the foul of the
party if you become the new personnel
grata
right xi jinping or whoever it is in the
politburo can reach right and snag that
from you
they're using it as tax havens they're
using as tax shelters
they're getting out of it and they know
by the way that the market is just super
hot right now
so it actually is in a financial sense a
very fantastic investment but it's the
financialization
of what is supposed to be and has
traditionally been this
wealth ownership this wealth generation
for middle class for working class
families
that now is being completely turned into
the next commodities market
you don't have landlords anymore you've
got some guy um who's owning it on wall
street they set up like a front company
to manage the whole thing
right so it's not like you know it's not
like one guy oh i flipped a couple of
houses and now i've got like 10. i had a
cousin who had
you know he had 10 houses in the
indianapolis area so he's
he's running it himself basically maybe
he has a couple people working for him
but it's not that anymore doesn't you
know call centers and
and and you know mechanics that are all
aren't there a bunch of
chinese like you mentioned chinese
wealthy people but isn't like large
swaths of land in the west just like
open
acreage bought by wealthy chinese
families and farmland too
yeah yeah absolutely and this is there's
a ton
of stuff that they're putting in because
people understand that you know when you
say
ccp in china you know it
you know people have this tendency and
it makes sense that you want to put that
into amer an american perspective right
we
we categorize things by trying to put
into boxes that are familiar to us but
there isn't anything like the ccp in the
united states because it's
well they say well you know their
government stops here and their business
starts there
so that's that's the separation no there
is no separation there's no real
separation and these
these aren't necessarily sort of like
nefarious plots right
this is just a general strategy that
they're employing they say real they
realize that if they own this farmland
then they can control u.s output they
can get
better consumption for chinese goods
obviously their consumption of this is
going to be much more than us
they know that in many cases when they
were fighting back against these tariffs
that president trump was was employing
when he first got in joe biden by the
way
has kept a lot of these tariffs in place
because they are widely popular they're
extremely popular
and they know though that the farmers of
the us
are doing a lot of sales on the
international market a lot of that ends
up in china
they can kind of set the prices on this
but they realize hey if we own the land
then we can just control the farms
directly do you know who the
who the largest private farmland owners
in the united states is
this is the one where it's bill gates
it's bill gates bill gates is the
largest private farmland owner in the
u.s
good for him yeah regarding rolling the
sleeves up i'm glad something good
finally happened for that guy but hold
on
let me sorry there's more the gates
aren't the only one percenters with dirt
in their portfolios of the last decade
farmland has taken off as an
asset class finance speak for a type of
investment that wall street sales people
urge wealthy people to include in their
well-balanced portfolios
the basic pitch by land they aren't
making it anymore so it's not just bill
gates i mean there's a lot of
conspiracies about why he's doing it
i think he just wants to own land i
think owning land is a really smart
investment
that's what they say to people by land
the point is the billionaires are buying
it up
they're also buying up bitcoin i don't
think they expect to lose money on these
things
but when working-class people
middle-class people can't buy these
things they can buy bitcoin
i'm not saying they should you know
don't get advice from me but if they
can't buy land
then what can they transfer to their to
their kids what will they own a desire
for land
this is what's scary and sort of um i
want to jump back to
part of the discussion on real estate
but i will say this as well i know that
earlier this year china was buying
so much they were buying up so many of
the corn futures or so much corn
features that they ended up pushing the
market to an eight year high
so they seem yeah so they seem to be
very interested in this
um i know also that with these massive
companies purchasing
real estate part of what frightens me
about that i
mentioned this earlier when i said that
people who don't own property are easier
to control is that
we have seen payment processors and
credit card companies in the past
decline service to people who they
disagree with politically or who are
very controversial
who's to say that these massive
companies don't get woke take a stand
and say we're not going to rent to
bigots
wow it's almost like bitcoin solves a
lot of that
regarding the chinese purchase of land
so if if a chinese citizen
bought land the ccp could seize that
land from that chinese person because
they're a chinese citizen is that right
not easily right but they could they you
know they could but it
more likely than not it would put in
some kind of arbitrary let's say they if
it's if it's a jail or something if it's
american land
they would have to do it through the
person right the chinese government's
not going to come to the united states
government here we'll be like that legal
document that says that person owns it
we own it now we're going to be like get
out of here but they could station
chinese troops on that piece of land
like okay if if a chinese citizen
buys a piece of land in the united
states does the united states still own
the land like how does that work who
owns that
property united states still has global
sovereignty
property tax from that person china
can't put troops there
no they can they can't do that what
about police they can put spies what
about like private
they can put spy surreptitiously but
that's your private security probably
the farther the
private sector they could they could
hire and station private security in
chinese
and those private security have to
operate under u.s laws with proper use
right until the war breaks out they can
do the things you would do on your own
before the war breaks out the us
military goes in and sweeps it out like
yeah but how much land do they own
that's my concern if they're buying
it if if war breaks out they don't own
any land that's the best part
all of the debt that china holds in the
u.s if right now just like you know
joe biden's sitting there and he just
like he's like falling asleep and then
he
goes oh i declare war on china oh what
happened our death's gone
there's no debt when you're at what
imagine being like imagine some guy
being like you owe me 100 bucks
and then he and then punching him in the
face
where you're fighting my concern is if
they buy up thousands of farms
and then station private security all
over the place chinese private security
and then
that's just an insurgent insurance well
i mean the goal
the goal is financial directly right and
this is something where
you know and i've had large
disagreements with people on this this
very question
over you know are we falling into
you know the the thucydides trap right
is is there an
un is there an uh impossible to get away
from
war with china that we are hurtling
towards is this
inevitable is this something that cannot
be stopped and i look the way i look at
it is
i i think something more like the great
reset is is more like what's inevitable
because
china doesn't want to go to war with us
we're their biggest customer
right they want us to be in that
consumer mode
they want us to be in that constant
state of
like you said not not owning property
not worrying about
you know trying to generate wealth of
our own as long as it's enough
where we're purchasing their goods we're
not causing any problems we're not
getting involved too much with the real
you know the actual realities on the
ground as the way things look
um you know are in china you know don't
worry about those uyghurs you know don't
worry about those people in hong kong
don't worry about the freedom fighters
that are you know constantly being
detained throughout china we just saw
the uh
this huge protest in nanjing university
right normal university which
um might seem kind of insignificant like
university protest whatever
um you know we have those in the us what
like every five minutes in china that's
a big deal in china that's quite a big
deal there are workers protests in china
and the provinces on a fairly regular
basis but they're just not
heard about in in u.s media they don't
have social media access so we don't
know about it a lot but
it's it's a constant thing this and in
the mid 2000s is going on a lot
but for students to protest like that i
mean
you know and obviously we're in very
close proximity to the uh the
anniversary of tiananmen square
and nowhere near on that scale right
because tiananmen wasn't even just
beijing it was all over the country but
to see any chinese students
at you know kids in their 20s basically
standing up against
the the government because essentially i
don't know the story the idea was
they had been going to what were
considered private universities but the
ministry of education had come in and
said
yeah you're not going to be private any
versus universities anymore we're going
to consolidate you down we're going to
consider you
these these to be vocational tech
schools at this point so it's basically
kind of like
like imagine if you would spend all the
money to go to a private university and
then
you know the government comes in and
says yeah that's a community college now
so you know your call your you know your
degree is worth
it it was worth here and now it's worth
here and in china that's still a
huge huge deal so the kids go nuts they
go absolutely nuts and the police came
in
and were just completely brutal with
them but the difference is
this went super viral all across chinese
media
what the recently social last week yeah
oh yeah and they like locked the city
down didn't they
uh yeah the whole city got put under
lockdown um it was multiple campuses
where this thing broke out
uh at one point the the chinese
government came out and the ccp saying
oh well they took the dean hostage right
and so
that's why we had to go in right and i
was and i don't yeah you wonder if they
were actually taking kind of like a
black lives matter
sort of take on things but then the kids
posted
pictures of the guy and he had he had
like a box of chicken and a soda and he
said no
he came and sat down with us and you
could see like other kids sitting around
with them and so
yeah i know what you're saying evergreen
it's kind of hard to tell but
it didn't look like a hostage i mean at
evergreen college they definitely you
know locked the administrators and
they're like we didn't hold anybody
hostage like they weren't free to leave
though
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you